I thought Picard's season 3 was
brilliant it had a few mistakes in it
that we were irritating but other than
that I loved it
but then I watched it again
I'm not sure I like it anymore
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV the
movie channel
[Music]
so I really enjoyed Picard season three
and even after watching it again I will
still say it is a vast Improvement on
seasons one and two of Picard it's a
million times better it makes more
bloody sense in almost every way and was
way more interesting more rounded
better written everything
but
I think I might have got swept up with a
Nostalgia of Picard season three a
little bit and I actually think watching
it again I didn't enjoy it anything like
as much as I enjoyed it the first time
around now before I get into explaining
why I'm actually thinking now that this
wasn't as good as show as I thought
let's get into things I loved Wharf in
this season was brilliant Riker was
actually brilliant in the way Riker
banked off everybody in this season to
be honest was an absolute Joy Riker in
most of the episodes was the linchpin of
everything he was bouncing up a card
bouncing off Wharf bouncing off seven of
nine he really was probably the most
important character in the entire series
I would actually argue way more than
Picard was I liked Jordy laforge's
return even though I thought he didn't
get as much screen time as he deserved
and data we'll leave that for a second
I'll come back to it but there were
really strong bits of this series mainly
being Captain vatic played by plumber
now she was amazing she chewed through
every scene she was absolutely fantastic
glorious in every moment I was good she
died in the way she did and she didn't
make it to the finale but in all honesty
I liked the way the changelings were
brought into this I know some of the
commentators have actually argued that
why would you bring in a villain from a
show that was nothing to do with the
show you're basing it on there was
nothing to do the Next Generation
basically but I would argue hey this is
a Star Trek feeling the reason why the
villain was there the reason why the
villain was helping the Borg in fact
made sense
that was one of the main things I liked
about this series was that it was
logical some commentators as well have
argued that actually bringing in the
Borg was a massive disappointment well I
can say that I think it was foreseeable
I knew from around the second episode
actually about five minutes into the
first episode there's so many Borg
references on wall 359 references I'm
like yeah this is going to be the Borg
the way they brought in that thing about
using the Transporters to assimilate
um as many people as possible and take
over the fleet that way I thought that
was genius the only thing I had a
problem with is that it was only
affected people that were under 25 but
again we'll come back to that in a
minute as well so what didn't I like
about Picard season 3
it was quite repetitive there was a lot
of parts in this series that actually
were just pretty much carbon copies of
the Star Trek movie The Wrath of Khan
there were several things about how for
example
um Beverly Crusher having to contact
Picard was mirrored again with Kirk and
his ex-wife that Kirk then met his son
picardment his son lots of the battles
with the shrike really reminded me of
again the battle between Kirk and Khan
so
I just found that they took a movie
which was good and they'd copied it
now this has been done before you could
argue actually that a couple of the JJ
Abrams movies kind of did the same thing
that they took the movie that they were
mirroring the motion picture the wrath
of karna Search for Spock and they just
sort of then did their own version of it
but with Picard season three
they pretty much repeated it almost to
verbatim in parts to the point where
once you realized what you were
basically watching was a stretched out
version of The Wrath of Khan you could
actually predict what was going to
happen and well predict it quite
accurately another film I thought that
they basically ripped off a fair bit was
Star Trek first Contact I mean to the
point where they took a little bit of
um the locutus storyline for example
from The Best of Both Worlds which they
referenced constantly but then the
actual scene where Jack was taken and
became locutus was pretty much ripped
Straight From First Contact instead of
it being data it was Jack Crusher Picard
had to come in have that big
conversation with the queen I don't know
where the queen didn't go just go dead
but she didn't
um and basically
almost again scene by scene it's a
straight up copy of the first Contact
finale scene now this leads me into the
whether this was just an exercise in fan
service now I don't have a problem with
fan service
in a way I think sometimes filmmakers TV
makers Etc they have to do something
original they have to do something a
little bit different and um you know if
they get accused of doing the same thing
again it's almost like a death nail in
their coffin
but actually just doing what the fans
want from time to time isn't a problem
we don't want massively overly
complicated storylines that don't make
bloody sense we want simple
entertainment
sometimes
sometimes we do want to be reminded we
do want nostalgic episodes that remind
us of a good old day when you know we
were watching the Next Generation for
the first time all those years ago but
when you have an entire series
the over and over again that's all it's
doing it doesn't necessarily make for a
show that you want to watch more than
once and this gets me to the repeated
mistakes in the series that were Silly
now some of them were just continuity
errors not a major problem but some of
them were quite major ones
now I've done a video talking about the
Enterprise G and how it was renamed from
the Titan
in all honesty
I can't help but think the moral of the
story and this is gonna we're gonna
wander into the Borg again now but the
moral of the story for Picard season 3
is that old things are cool and anything
new is crap
and on a very simple level that's kind
of what it's saying I mentioned the Borg
and how they only assimilated the over
25s now they came up with some very
vague biological reason why that would
be in all honesty it really should have
affected everybody and if you think from
an actual plan if they'd have planned to
only take over the 25 that's a stupid
way of doing it because you're basically
creating
an opportunity for your enemy to defeat
the under-25s you would just assimilate
everybody that went through the
transporter regardless you might miss a
couple that way but in the Federation at
this time 99.9 of Starfleet would all of
a sudden and instantaneously become the
Borg so it doesn't make any sense that
it was designed that way and it doesn't
really any make any sense from a
biological point of view why that would
be the only way it could be designed
so
that was a problem it was set up because
they needed to be able to defeat the
Borg so the original crew had to survive
the assimilation and be able to fight
back
but with all the woke culture at the
moment with all of the negativity
through the internet and through YouTube
and basically a lot of people shouting
that you know the youth that today are
really the problem in society I mean you
could argue that every culture ever has
always blamed the Youth of today but
that seems to be really active at the
moment and Picard season three
unintentionally I assume is basically
reinforcing that belief that everybody
under 25 is the Borg and they're the
problem and really what we need is the
older generation to come and save us
I'm sure that's not what Terry metallis
meant
but between that and the Enterprise
renaming that made no sense
I don't know it feels like that's the
moral of the story now with somebody
over 25 I'm kind of okay with it because
I didn't want to be assimilated
but
the story has to be logical and I'm
afraid once again for new track
it just wasn't
data was always always my favorite
character when he died at the end of
Nemesis I was genuinely cut up when we
saw before at the end started to sing
the song I thought all data could come
back I was actually quite excited I have
always been a massive fan of Brent Spina
and his acting ability
the way they brought data back in this
one was
imaginative in a way even though they
said he was created as a core as a
security program basically for The
daystream Institute it didn't 100 make
sense that they had actually built him
the way they did they could have just
built a positronic brain and done it
that way but no the daystrom tried to
get him to replicate data now I could
understand technologically why they'd
want to do that I don't know why they
made him an old man but you know again
for the story to happen that's the way
it had to work
but data came back but he was different
because again that's where they have to
do it nowadays they can something can
come back but it has to be different but
anyway he was
whole scene between him and law when he
was giving him his memories now I can
kind of follow why they were doing it
because he was absorbing those memories
so by absorbing them he became more data
but the way they did it was if data had
defeated him by doing that
the whole scene to be honest was very
fluffy
not sure it made sense
and I can't help but think there would
have been a better way to do it the
worst thing about this bloody series and
I didn't like it the first time around
and I hated it even more the second and
third time round was the space babies a
nebula exploding and turning into
billions of space jellyfish
didn't make any sense
if nebulous ever exploded like that I'm
pretty sure scientists somewhere would
have noticed it doesn't really make
sense
again in any way I thought when they
were dropping into the nebula again very
Wrath of Carney that
um the
the biometric energy that they were
detecting was something to do with the
changelings that maybe they'd created a
new Link in the middle of this nebula so
what they're actually detecting was that
changeling link even though it was a
lake that we saw on the changeling's
home World maybe this version of the
changelings were existing within this
nebula they were hiding there this and
they take on you know a gaseous form I
don't know if that's possible or not but
a gaseous form within the nebula and
that's how they're surviving but then
when it turned out to know it'd just be
a massive space egg
I just thought
why did it go off while they were there
it wouldn't mean more sense if something
to do with the battle that was going on
was what actually triggered the birth
then I could have followed it a bit more
I would go okay they they triggered it
you know they they cracked the egg sort
of thing but that wasn't the case they
just happened to be there at the time
that this thing happened
my other issue is though this is
supposed to be Science Fiction it's
supposed to be based in some sort of
reality we could understand and I'm
sorry but a nebula popping into a
billion space babies
by the time the Federation was around
we'd have seen that even if it was
incredibly rare I think we would have
known about it by now
I don't get any of the actual signs
behind how it worked in the first place
but even the fact that it did I just
think
nobody's ever seen it before ever it
didn't really make sense to me I thought
it was cheesy I thought it was badly
written and even though I understand why
they did it to help Ryka sort of like
refined his imagination in his joyful
you know exploring
I just thought it was stupid and to be
honest watching it again it's even more
stupid so I loved Picard season three
and there are bits of this series that I
really do love but to be honest the
Nostalgia just overtook me I enjoyed it
because we were seeing the Enterprise D
again even though that was incredibly
predictable I enjoyed seeing Riker and
wolf and Geordie and data and everybody
else again
but once the Nostalgia and the
excitement of that passes
it's just another Star Trek show
Taylor's did a much better job in lots
of ways than other people behind Star
Trek recently have done and it actually
does stand up against a lot of sci-fi
that we've got around at the moment
but I compare it to the next Generation
I compare it to Voyager and I compare it
to D Space Nine and I'm sorry but
everything new Trek has been doing
doesn't stand up against those shows
strange new worlds came close
actually I loved lower decks even though
I'd say it's completely different it's
not really Star Trek even though strange
new worlds is going to bring it into
Star Trek in the next season I'll do a
video on that at some point
and to be honest Prodigy again is a kids
show
none of it's really track
I can only hope that Stargate does
return as you know we talk about a lot
on this channel very soon because
for me I'm losing patience with the Star
Trek franchise
I actually said if Picard season 3 was
bad I would turn my back on Star Trek
and I would never watch it again and I
am a tracking
it was good enough that I'm not going to
do that
but still
not good enough I'd love to know those
exactly what you think have you watched
Picard season three again do you
understand what I'm saying about the
Nostalgia kind of washed over me a
little bit and actually watching it
again it's maybe not as good as I
thought first time around or am I
talking absolute rubbish was This
brilliant track and you know I should
stop moaning get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos which last
Sidetrack for a small contribution each
month you can see most of our new videos
first and without the adverts and
there's even an option for a seven day
free trial
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign